ça y est c'est l'été que vous preniez
les vacances ou pas vous allez avoir des
activités que vous n'avez pas le reste
de l'année
et du coup vous allez être confrontés à
des problèmes sans qu'elle ne vous
apprends mettant tout l'été des tc vous
aident à éviter les pièges et les
dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et
votre santé
dtc partenaire de votre été une petite
viande du seikan poisson des légumes
le barbecue c'est comme on aime mais
attention pour profiter de ce petit
bonheur culinaires et du reste de son
été est du reste de sa vie même
il ya deux trois petits trucs à savoir
d'abord le barbecue ça brûle en gueule
tu grandiras jamais en fait dit bah non
non si non sinon on parle quand même de
200 accidents chaque année en france qui
peuvent toucher un peu tout le monde
c'est à dire celui qui s'occupe du
barbecue
les gens qui sont autour et surtout les
enfants donc on va voir ce qu'il faut
faire en cas d'accident mais comme
prévenir c'est toujours mieux que guérir
quelques petites règles à respecter pour
se régaler son prix
avant même de commencer s'il ya des
enfants autour éloigner les tenez la
distance jusqu'à ce que le barbecue soi
et en assurez vous que le barbecue et
bien aux normes de sécurité et
choisissez bien l'endroit où vous aller
l'installer il faut que le terrain soit
bien plat pour que l'appareil soit
stable à l'abri du vent est bien dégagée
pour paraître le fait autour de ce soir
ne vous mettez pas sous un arbre ni à
côté du noël ni à côté d'une maison une
trop proche de matériel qu'il restera de
s'enflammer
c'est d'autant plus important de bien
choisir son emplacement qu'une fois que
le barbecue sera allumé faudra surtout
pas essayer de le déplacer
choisissez bien votre tenue aussi pas de
vêtements pas deux manches longues et
plus tôt du coton surtout pas du
synthétique parce que quand ça brûle sa
faune et sa colle à la peau prévoyez des
grandioses
une fois allumé ne ravive et jamais le
feu avec un liquide inflammable comme de
l'essence ou d'alcool à brûler et gardez
toujours à portée de main de quoi
éteindre les flammes si besoin comme un
saut ou un jet d'eau pour le surveiller
pour surveiller les gens qui sont autour
ne vous éloignez jamais trop du feu pas
trop près quand même et allez-y
doucement sur la période
aujourd'hui la route
une fois que vous avez terminé
éteignez bien votre barbecue et rester
vigilant tant qu'il n'a pas complètement
refroidie bon mais si malgré toutes ces
précautions un drame arrive quand même
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire premier cas
de figure quelqu'un est en feu et ses
vêtements brûle on l'a on est mal mais
il faut pas céder à la panique
première chose à faire demander à
quelqu'un d'appeler le samu au 15
éloigner la personne du barbecue et
empêché de courir çà attiserait les
flammes et il irait foutent le feu
partout ensuite dit lui de se met au sol
et trouver une couverture attention pas
en synthétique 1 pour les raisons qu'on
avait tout à l'heure n'importe quel gros
morceau de tissu fera la faire c'est
pour le recouvrir étouffer les flammes
si vous n'avez pas ça sous la main vous
pouvez aussi lui demander de se rouler
par terre pour étendre le prêt une fois
que c'est fait fait doucement couler
l'eau à une vingtaine de degrés 20 cm
au-dessus des brûlures pendant 20
minutes
c'est pour refroidir et calmer les
douleurs retirer le reste des vêtements
sauf s'y colle à la peau et aussi les
bijoux les zones brûlées vont gonfler il
faut éviter que les bagues des bracelets
ou les chaînes restent branchés le temps
en attendant l'arrivée des secours il
faut lisser la victime sur le sol en
position de demi à 6 c'est à dire
légèrement penché vers l'arrière et
adossé sur quelque chose sauf s'il doit
été brûlées couvrez-la avec des linges
en coton propres et secs pour éviter une
hypothermie c'est à dire une chute
importante de la température corporelle
à cause des brûlures et du
refroidissement
en attendant les secours vous pouvez
aussi commander des pizzas parce qu'on
va pas se mentir le barbecue c'est mort
par contre ne donnait rien à manger ni
même à boire à la victime et aller
siroter un peu plus loin ce riche
héritage à son deuxième cas maintenant
moins dramatique mais grave quand même
les vêtements sont pas en feu mais
quelqu'un s'est brûlé à une grande
partie des conseils qu'on vient de voir
reste valable
on éloigne la victime du barbecue ont
fait couler l'eau à 20 degrés pendant 20
minutes 20 cm au-dessus des brûlures on
enlève les bijoux et les vêtements sauf
s'il y colle à la peau on enveloppe la
brûlure dans un linge propre en coton et
attention il ya des cloques qu'on ne
perce pas et on ne met rien de suivre
sans l'avis d'un médecin
si la brûlure est grave il faut appeler
le 15 alors vous allez
et comment on fait comment ça y est ça
recommence
d'abord chez des enfants de moins de
cinq ans une personne de plus de 60 ans
ou quelqu'un qui est une maladie
chronique comme du diabète une
insuffisance cardiaque
une maladie qui affaiblit son système
immunitaire une brûlure c'est toujours
grave
pour le reste tout dépend de trois
choses l'étendue de la brûlure sa
profondeur et sa localisation
toutes les brûlures au niveau du visage
du cou des mains ou des organes génitaux
sont considérés comme graves toute
brûlure de plus de 10% de la surface
corporelle totale c'est grave aussi pour
calculer sa la paume de la main de la
victime c'est à peu près 1% sa surface
corporelle et enfin en classe la
profondeur des brûlures en degrés le
premier degré ça correspond à peu près à
un coude sur les classiques au deuxième
degré superficielle des cloques apparaît
sur une peau rouge noir fendillé et la
gravité apparaît à partir du 2ème degré
profond avec destruction de l'épiderme
des cloques des parties blanchâtre et
des zones sensibles au troisième degré
la peau et comme du carton sèche
anesthésié parfois noir à ce stade la
destruction nucléaire mais total et la
chirurgie est obligatoire dans tous les
cas si vous avez un doute appeler le 15
et vous diront quoi faire bon allez pas
vous respecter la règle de sécurité il
ya aucune raison que ce genre de avant
de se quitter un dernier truc il n'y a
pas qu'en voulant que dans notre
chronique terminale quand la grèce du
poisson de la viande coule sur les
braises s'apprend et des flammes de la
fumée qui au contact des aliments forme
des substances cancérigènes les
hydrocarbures aromatiques polycycliques
et la cuisson à trop de température au
barbecue ou pas d'ailleurs ça favorise
la formation d'acides aminés
hétérocycliques eux aussi cancérigènes
donc retenu ce conseil
quand c'est cramé faut pas manger là
encore quelques petits conseils pour
pouvoir profiter d'un barbecue sans
risque
nettoyez la grille avant la cuisson
allumez votre feu à l'ancienne ou si
vous utilisez un accélérateur prenait
101 qui est fait pour ça et attendez
qu'il est complètement brûlé avant de
mettre aux aliments a grillé
du charbon épuré pour éviter les
émanations toxiques évitez les viandes
et les poissons trop gras et retirer les
buttes grèce avant la crise on pouvait
faire mariner tout ça dans la bière
fruits dans la pierre parce que ça a un
effet protecteur envers des fruits et
des légumes pour les mêmes raisons
placez les aliments du cm minimum au
dessus des braises ça correspond à peu
près à une température de 220 degrés il
vaut mieux que ça cuit doucement avec la
chaleur mais surtout pas au contact et
l'a6 est cramé faut pas manger donc
retirer les morceaux noir si vous faites
de la viande
je suis est là bien pour éviter les
intoxications alimentaires et puis même
si c'est tentant
cette barre depuis tous les jours deux
fois par semaine c'est bien voilà dtc
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve non pas la semaine prochaine
mais dans quinze jours pour une nouvelle
vidéo spécialité en attendant bonnes
vacances à ceux qu'ont donc bon courage
à ceux qui n'ont pas et pour tout le
monde
mettez vous bien et portez vous